[Music]
all the numbers are clear the American
people you are facing the burden of
bomic that has not stopped the
administration from just outright lying
about it take a look at what your
president said earlier
today a conversation a conversation
about whether we'd have enough left over
at the end of the month for my dad to be
able used to say have a little bit of
breathing room well this past week as
Americans gathered around their own
kitchen tables for Thanksgiving dinner
that was our goal to give them a little
more breathing room and together we made
progress you know from Turkey to air
travel to tank of gas cost went down
they went down all right let's break it
down according to the usda's own
analysis food prices have been soaring
in Biden's failed economy by the way
they expect up 5.8% this year alone gas
prices will have risen well over a
dollar since January of 2021 that's not
even at its height uh but of course they
are resorting to their favorite tactic
when all else fails just blame Donald
Trump who now has been out of office
almost three years for their failures
take a look but why do you think it is
that when you say the economy is
improving and President Biden says the
economy is improving that a majority of
Americans outside of this building are
not buying it so here's the
thing when we walked into this
Administration the economy was on a tail
a tail spin
that is the fact because of the last
administration because of the Trump
administration because of how they dealt
with uh with dealt with covid and the
pandemic because they didn't have a
comprehensive plan uh okay it was also
during the middle of covid but let's add
one other point Donald Trump didn't add2
trillion more dollars last year alone to
the debt that we're putting on our kids
and grandkids but voters we all know
they're not buying it as they continue
to sour on bomic and Joe's ability to to
handle the economy here with reaction
he's the host of cudow on our sister
Network the Fox Business Network our
friend Larry cudow even the Washington
Post reporter you know pretty much
nailed it where you know saying that uh
Biden nomics is now a negative word
Politico saying the panic in the
Democratic party should be about the
economy not about Joe uh and his age and
his and his cognitive decline um I think
it's all the above I don't think it's
working for the American people and I
can use every measurable statistic
imaginable to make that point
Larry well I don't understand I mean the
bidens are incapable of telling the
truth about this economy so when the
press secretary says she inherited a a
quote reeling economy which is what the
bidens have said uh for three years can
I just remind Donald Trump handed them a
6 and a
half% economic growth rate in the first
quar quarter of
2021 with a 1 and a half% inflation rate
so I would say that was a pretty
spectacular economy and then when
President Biden says well the turkey you
bought for Thanksgiving was down I don't
understand that either compared to the
Thanksgiving in 2020 which was Donald
Trump's last in office I mean the
American Farm Bureau I'll just read you
this stuff I'm not making this up the
American Farm Bureau says a Thanksgiving
dinner was 41% higher than at the end of
2020 turkey up
41% ham up
97% pumpkin pie up
31% and potatoes up
34% uh Sean I want you to stay off those
potatoes because they're too expensive
for your waistline so I don't know what
she is talking about here I mean it's
just they are incapable of telling the
truth that's the bottom line well thanks
a lot Larry I mean I've only worked hard
on my diet for 6 months I really
appreciate the vote of confidence that
you've given me uh and Tak it in far
less I couldn't help I can't help myself
it's too much no you really can't and
and don't worry I'll get you back um the
funny thing is and the and the sad thing
is you know early in my adult life I did
live paycheck to paycheck I know what
that life is like for too many early
adult years that I've had
that that is all etched into my memory
bank I don't want to ever have to go
back there but now we have a case where
61% of Americans now are living paycheck
to paycheck many other Americans are not
making you know just ends meet every
month for their Bare Necessities you see
people now putting Bare Necessities on
their credit cards they're cashing in
their pensions early uh and it's costing
them a fortune and I don't see any way
out and I don't see any plan
to to stop this from happening or you
know if you're not going to face the
truth and the truth is just bad how do
you fix
it well I think you know on that point
look at credit card interest rates are
upwards of
30% uh car loans are over 10% mortgage
rates hovering around 8% those are
hugely hugely bigger than they were
three years ago and look at here's
another thing I want to raise this
evening if you look at the economic
statistics I don't want to be too boring
here but the index of leading economic
indicators which tells you whether
you're going into recession or going
into a Prosperity that index is down 19
straight months it is a big huge
recession warning for 2024 and then you
look inside that you know business in
investment is down housing uh starts and
sales are down uh these things are you
know Wall Street doesn't believe it but
I'm just looking at the actual facts and
I'm suggesting that there's a very high
risk probably 65% or better of a
recession next year despite what Wall
Street may or may not think now look it
prices have gone up faster than wages so
people are living paycheck to paycheck
and they're having trouble not only with
higher prices but they're having trouble
with higher interest rates this is why
Mr Biden's approval rating on the
economy and that includes particularly
in the swing States why his approval
rating is so bad people are smarter than
the Geniuses think people at ordinary
working folks okay trying to earn a
living lower income folks who have to
suffer through these high prices in many
ways they're a lot smarter than
economists and they are very concerned
what's happening now and what may happen
next year and look at look at the
housing new home construction screeching
halt uh sale of pre-existing homes
virtually non-existent who who in
America is going to give up a 3% 30-year
fix rate mortgage for an an 8 plus perc
30-year fixed rate mortgage nobody that
means nobody's going to sell the house
they're in unless they have
to and and and I would say business
which is really the heart of the economy
we produce to consume business is so
important small business so important
right now what you're seeing business
investment is down business new orders
are down these are very big warning
signs and once again I think Main Street
America may be a lot smarter than the
economics profession all right Larry
cuddo great to see you appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else